hi guys sci-fi recapped here today I am
going to explain the film called the
main event spoilers ahead watch out and
stay safe the movie revolves around an
11 year old boy named Leo from
fallbridge who lives with his Dad Steve
and maternal grandmother Denny's Leo is
passionate about wrestling and he
aspires to become a successful WWE
wrestler like his role model WWE
Superstar Kofi Kingston Leo also has a
mother named Rachel but she has
disappeared from his life without any
explanation meanwhile Leo's father is
going through financial hardships and he
is currently working as a taxi driver
and car mechanic to support the family
one day Leo rides his bike to school and
meets up with his friends Riaz and Caleb
they also appear to be crazy about
wrestling the three then discuss a
secret announcement that the WWE is set
to make Riaz who is passionate about
filming hopes that WWE is set to
announce something related to them
looking for a new cameraman the
suggestion makes Caleb laugh so Riaz
gets back at him by replying that Caleb
is laughing because he has no passions
of his own it's then revealed that the
school is organizing a talent show and
Leo's friends encourage him to sign up
for the wrestling competition however
Leo turns them down as if he feels that
he is not strong enough to win suddenly
bullies Trevor Mason and Luke show up
the former signs up for wrestling and
Bullies Leo for being scared this
attracts the attention of a teacher who
reprimands the bullies and sends them to
the principal's office later at the
cafeteria Leo finds himself staring at
his Crush Erica and ends up dropping
spaghetti on his pants making a fool out
of himself after school the bullies
confront me of forgetting them in
trouble when he flees they chase him on
their bikes Leo manages to get away and
hide inside a house that's holding an
estate sale the bullies also follow him
into the house but the real estate
broker chases them away meanwhile Leo
finds a mysterious box with a wrestling
mask inside in his Hideout The Mask
smells rancid but Leo is nevertheless
mesmerized by it to his good luck the
real estate broker lets him keep it
making him happy that night Leo watches
wrestling with Denise he wishes that he
was as strong as Kofi saying that
everything would be so much better
however Denise tells him that life isn't
all about being physically strong one
has to be strong mentally and
emotionally this reminds Leo of his
mother as she used to say this all the
time then WWE announces that they are
set to come to fallbridge to look for
the next NXT Superstar the finalists
will square off inside a steel cage and
the winner will get a NXT contract along
with a fifty thousand dollars cash prize
meanwhile Steve returns home from work
and Leo tries to talk to him about his
mother Rachel however Steve changes the
topic and walks away later Denise
confronts Steve and calls him out for
avoiding the Rachel topic around Leo
it's then revealed that Rachel abandoned
her family for another man and Steve
doesn't want to tell Leo to protect his
feelings unfortunately the little boy
overhears the conversation he learns
that Stevo's twenty thousand dollars to
the bank and if he fails to pay back the
amount the family might lose the house
Leo gets upset so he wears the mask
keeper brought home earlier to cheer
himself up lo and behold he discovers
that it is a magical mask which
transforms him it deepens his voice and
gives him super physical strength he
spends all night researching the mask
and learns that it is a legendary mask
and only a genuinely deserving Champion
can use its powers the next day Trevor
and his friends again pick on Leo so he
teaches them a lesson using the mask
this makes the masked boy famous in
school and his Crush Erica also notices
him in the next scene Leo decides to
participate in the NXT auditions and
gives himself a wrestling Alias kid
chaos at the auditions he befriends a
fellow contestant named Smooth Operator
after the first round of auditions
several contestants including kid chaos
Smooth Operator and an obnoxious
wrestler named Samson make the cut later
when Leo Returns home and tries to sneak
into his room through the window he is
caught by Denise and is forced to come
clean about the mask and his NXT
Ambitions he mentions that he knows
about his mother and the loan on Steve's
head so wants to help the family by
taking part in the NXT Denise tries to
make him understand that he is a kid and
that he doesn't have to worry about the
loans taken by his father however Leo
has already made up his mind after a lot
of insisting he finally convinces his
grandma the next day Leah summons the
courage to talk to Erica using the mask
and invites her home for group study
when she arrives Leo tries to use the
mask to transform his personality but
its smell puts Erica off therefore Leo
is forced to put it aside and rely on
his real personality to talk to her
later he advances to the semi-finals
after winning matches against his
opponents this makes kid chaos famous
throughout the town even among Caleb and
Luke who are unaware that kid chaos is
actually Leo Smooth Operator also makes
it to the semi-finals and he and Leo
congratulate each other the two get to
talking and Leo learns that smooth has
been trying to get into wrestling for
more than a decade he reveals that he
started training in college and gave
several auditions for the WWE but
couldn't get signed however smooth
hasn't lost hope and he is confident
that he'll make it this time around one
afternoon Steve tries to spend time with
Leo however when the little kid brings
up his mother Steve again gets awkward
and changes the topic Denise again talks
to him and advises him not to let the
uncomfortable truth about Leah's mother
stop him from spending time with his son
later Leo meets up with Caleb Luke and
Erica at a diner the kids talk about the
talent show and Leo encourages Erica to
Showcase her dancing skills when she
expresses her apprehensions about
dancing by herself Leo offers to become
her dance partner much to Caleb and
Luke's surprise just then an armed man
enters the diner and tries to rob it
everyone cowers in fear but Leo decides
to put on his mask and stop the robber
in the process he exposes his identity
to his friends Caleb and Luke are amazed
while Leo's bravery gives Erica the
courage to participate in the talent
show she makes Leo her dance partner and
they spend their evenings practicing
their dance routine at Caleb's home in
the NXT Samson makes it to the finals
while smooth and kid chaos go head to
head for their spot in the fine kid
chaos growing popularity starts to
bother Samson so the latter's manager
Frankie puts an adhesive liquid on his
shoes but Despite All Odds our
protagonist manages to defeat smooth and
advance to the finals much to Frankie's
dismay however Frankie discovers the
truth about the mask meanwhile Leo gets
Carried Away by his growing popularity
and he ditches Erica's talent show for a
media interview as a result she is
forced to perform alone Erica butchers
the initial part of her routine until
Caleb joins her on stage and dances
effortlessly giving her the much needed
courage it turns out Caleb is passionate
about something after all Leo arrives
after the talent show ends and he makes
up an excuse for being late however he
gets called out for lying by Riaz who
saw him spending all evening taking
pictures with his fans instead of
apologizing Leo doubles down on his
behavior which further enraged his
friends in the next scene he returns
home upset and when Steve tries to talk
to him Leo pushes him away seeing this
Denise speaks to Leo and the latter
confesses is that he thought the mask
would solve all of his problems but
things are only getting worse Denise
calms him down and advises him to talk
it out with his friends before things
get any worse the next day Leo goes to
talk to his dad but realizes that
Stephen has already left for work later
he talks to his friends and apologizes
for his mistake the friends accept his
apology and he invites them to his final
match that evening Frankie speaks to Leo
in the locker room and apologizes to him
for putting adhesive on his shoes as the
two talk Samson secretly switches Leo's
magical mask with a regular one
afterwards Leo puts on his costume and
heads for the final match the game is
guest refereed by WWE Superstar Sheamus
Leo's Idol Kofi Kingston is also in
attendance the match begins and Leo soon
realizes that something's wrong when he
isn't able to counter any of Samson's
attacks after a while Samson pulls out
the real mask from his pocket shocking
Leo Samson then tries to put the mask on
but it doesn't fit his big head
frustrated he throws it up in the air
and inadvertently sticks at high up up
on the cage just then kid chaos takes
off his fake mask revealing his identity
to the world Leo then tries to convince
Samson against fighting but the latter
continues to attack him the giant
wrestler picks the boy up and throws him
high up in the air fortunately Leo
manages to grab onto the cage referee
she misintervenes and orders Samson to
back off but instead gets knocked out
Samson then shakes the cage to make Leo
fall down meanwhile Steve returns home
and finds the house empty he helps
himself to some food and watches TV to
pass time soon he comes across the WWE
match and becomes stunned to see his son
fighting against a giant wrestler he
immediately rushes to The Venue Steve is
upset that his son didn't inform him
about it however he knows that Leo is
passionate about wrestling so he
encourages him he tells Leo that every
wrestler has a weakness and Samson is
possibly afraid of heights Frankie
overhears the conversation and orders
Samson to climb up the cage to prove
that he's not afraid of anything Samson
follows his orders but then Leo
challenges him to look down while
climbing an overwhelmed Samson obliges
and out of fear he ends up passing out
and collapsing on the ground meanwhile
Leo grabs hold of his magic mask but he
decides against using it he then jumps
down on Samson officially winning the
match as everyone celebrates Leo
apologizes to his dad for not telling
him about this competition Steve
forgives him and finally comes clean
that his mother left for another man the
little boy simply smiles and hugs his
dad in the final scene Leah wins a fifty
thousand dollars check and since he
can't sign a contract with WWE as an 11
year old he asks them to give smooth an
opportunity the WWE officials agree and
tell Leo that when he gets older there
will be a place for him in the
organization two weeks later Leo is seen
on the school wrestling team he has
gained confidence without the mask and
gets to wrestle Trevor with his dad
cheering him on from the audience
thanks for watching subscribe and hit
that like button to help our Channel
grow turn on the notifications so you
won't miss any of our new videos